so welcome everyone to this talk titled
beyond JavaScript frameworks making
reliable web apps with Elm so how many
of you know how who jonathan is hands up
quite a few
so Jonathan IO is a chief design officer
at Apple and a very critical person in
the development of all the recent major
Apple projects so this is my favorite
quote about Elm it was made by one of my
colleagues explaining Elm to a fellow
graphical designer so Elm is like
Jonathan I've made a programming
language it is minimalistic it is user
friendly and it just works so of course
this is a little bit biased but I think
that in a way it kind of captures Elm
so my goal for the next hour is to
explain why I think this quote is so
great and I'm and why else great so I'm
going to do this through a two-part
agenda first I'm going to share you with
you how Elm works and how you build apps
with it and why I think it has such a
great potential and finally I'm going to
share a little bit about Elm in Norway
the own community and who is used using
Elm and what are they using it for and
what are their experiences so I guess
it's about time to deduce myself my name
is Eric and I work at the place in also
called Becky consulting rather large
consultancy with about 400 people and I
specialize in JavaScript and large SBA's
so pretty much for entirety of my career
I've been working with large single page
apps both with JavaScript and the design
part and working with JavaScript is real
fun because it's so flexible right you
can do basically everything so how many
of you would say that you are pretty
good at javascript so that's maybe about
half or between a third and a half so I
guess you can tell me what this is so
you could take this and paste into your
script console and it would print out
something it could be so good yes but
it's not it's hello and ECE
so it's actually possible to deduce it
if you learn the rules of how this crazy
thing works so I thought I'd just start
to talk by taking you through this
little detour of how beautiful and crazy
javascript will
is so I'm going to give myself an
assignment we're going to create the
letter e which i think is a brilliant
letter it's the most frequent letter of
the English language and it's also the
first letter in my name so I like it so
it's about time for a little demo so I'm
only going to use six letters I'm going
to use the Hadley called angle brackets
like these ones and their parents the
plus and the exclamation mark so in
JavaScript I just love working with
arrays because arrays are so flexible
just like the language itself they're
actually objects I'm not the proper
array type so you can do a lot of cool
stuff for them you could take an array
and curse it into a boolean value so it
would have to be either a true or false
and really if we negate it an array it
would do just that and become become
false because an array is true if you
try to get truthiness out of it so you
could do that again and we'd have a
pretty short word that contains letter E
so we are approaching our goal but we
need that to be a string and everyone
knows something arrays together yields
an empty string so we could just take
the truth eval you submit with an array
and boom there we have our E as a string
in a string and as you can take strings
like this and fetch out a single letter
based on their index we can basically do
this but now we're cheating we can't use
the the letter 3 so we have to create
that somehow ok so back to our arrays
let's try to do arithmetic with our
array that's the plus array 0 and the 0
doesn't help us in obtaining a 3 so we'd
have to get 1 so let's go back to
coercing it into a boolean value because
0 that's basically true if you negate it
right and then we can take true and turn
that back into a number wallah and now
we just have to do this a couple of
times
then we've got three and then we take
this thing and try to extract that and
ice from our little true creator over
here there we go not that many groups
you have to jump through to get it to
work I actually wanted to make something
more complex like NBC but then we'd have
to get away to get a hold of the filter
function on the array.prototype and then
do a two-string on that and then fetch
the c on the native code so imagine
that's in the X what like and X 16 or
something so my talk would have been
mostly doing this so what's the point of
doing this to have script exercise so
it's hardly in use anymore javascript is
really wonky and the type system is
really bad or funny but it's a fact that
people a lot of people still love
JavaScript and build pretty amazing
stuff with it so javascript has been on
top on Stack Overflow for many years I'm
not sure if it still is but it has been
and on github in terms of usage presence
at conferences demand for new and shiny
frameworks and tools and innovation in
the open-source community has just been
tremendous so I mean you have this
jungle of JavaScript frameworks so
before I started using Elm I was a big
fan of react and redux and maybe with
some typescript on top and immutable j/s
and web pack and babel and there's the
list is pretty long of tools but I'm not
sure if javascript is the best tool for
writing single page apps anymore I don't
and I'm not sure if I'm convinced that
typescript is the answer either even
though it's a lot better than JavaScript
or fable or clojurescript or pure script
the list is very long of alternatives so
some rhetorical questions for you
did you ever ship a large SP a being
confident that it wouldn't crash in
production even though you didn't test
it or put it through lots of QA I know I
didn't in six years of full-time
JavaScript development did you have a
refactor an SBA confidence you didn't
break anything like how do you do that
you just
refactor the app and you run it and you
hope you fix all the bugs in console and
you just hope it works
you basically have to test every page
right you have to run through all the
code perhaps you were overwhelmed by the
amount of stuff you need to learn to
work with modern front-end so I'm a
practice lead for front-end development
at my company so I should be one of the
ones like most updated on the JavaScript
landscape but if you're really stressed
but just all the new stuff coming out so
JavaScript fatigue is really is a thing
and our everyone on your team really
comfortable doing front-end tasks
because I mean most of the teams I've
been a part of you have the people who
are really comfortable with front-end
and you have the people who are not and
that's always a pretty big group of the
team so for me 7 years full-time
front-end developer check check check
check and I think this is a big problem
I mean it's 2017 we have all these great
tools great languages these great
practices the still this is like the de
facto standard for a lot of people so in
my experience elm addresses all of these
problems so I'm going to show you how
does Elm work how do you build apps with
it and why do I think it has such great
potential
so Elm is a language that compiles to
JavaScript so it's not a framework like
redux or angular or view jas or all of
these others so it basically means that
you write your app and helm you compile
it to JavaScript file and then you just
add that to your site like this let's
say you have a main load JavaScript and
in a script tag you would just grab the
global Elm object and grab your app
called main and just embed that
somewhere in your document so it's
pretty easy to use element apart of your
app just like with react so that's how
Ellen fits into the like your your web
stack so looking at Elm at a glance it
compiles to JavaScript as I said it has
an extreme focus on robustness and
safety that means it shouldn't be able
to crash so there's a famous quote
saying no runtime errors like your code
will not crash or run time and it's an
ml family language so it's similar to a
scale that's the main inspiration even
though it's a lot simpler than Haskell
but it also resembles a camel or maybe
most interesting interesting
it's the most interesting language at
this conference f-sharp and
user-friendliness where the user is us
developers is a big priority email and
it's extremely opinionated it sets all
sorts of I mean it really is just really
opinionated for a lot of people that's a
big turn-off
and some of the main notable elm
language features is that all data is
immutable it's an expression oriented
language so there's no statements and
it's pure so all side effects like
searching something from the server or
generating a random number is handled by
the runtime so you don't have to do that
dirty call yourself you just say to Elm
hey please do this for me and you'll get
the data back or a failure and
architecture is a feature in the
language you don't have to pick should I
use Elm Redux or Elm angular or ell
reactive something you just use the Elm
architecture it's that choice has been
made for you and it has a pretty small
but expressive features that like Lego
blocks that just click together but it's
a lot smaller in terms of features than
let's say Haskell or perhaps even F
sharp so let's have a quick look at the
language so as a functional language
functions are at the core of the
language so this is a very simple
example function called increment that
takes one argument named X and we just
return X plus 1 and 5 is a constant I
would say the variable in JavaScript but
you can't change so it's constant that's
the result of calling the increment
function with number 4 and elm is full
type inference so it knows you can you
can infer all the types in your app so
since you are adding X to one with the
addition there are arithmetic addition
operator it knows that X must be
something that handles that and that's
just number so it has to be a number but
of course you could specify the type
signatures yourself and you should do
that because it's great documentation is
for other people who read your code and
also it allows the compiler to tell you
that hey you made you intended this
function to do this but now it does this
instead so maybe you maybe you did
something wrong and so we have constants
but we also have two pools which is
basically like a fixed length array that
can have a value
of different types like a pair of ends
and also we can have records which are
an equivalent of JavaScript objects just
a collection of key-value pairs
basically and please note that all the
type signatures have to be on the line
directly above the declaration so these
are the like the basic building blocks
but let's say we want to say that a
person or a customer it has a certain
shape we could use a type alias which is
a way to introduce new types into our
system so we could say that a
coordinates that's basically whenever we
have a pair of ends so they are totally
interchangeable it's not like a class or
a constructor or something you can just
say that whenever you have a variant you
could need to change the type signature
with coordinates same thing with this
count you can just say that we never
have an int is basically a discount as
well so it could make your code easier
to read in some cases but it really
becomes interesting when you use this
with records so you could say that a
customer has this shape and you can make
your customer with name and age so let's
say a customer has a type you have three
types of customers you have students you
have corporate customers and you have
private customers so we'd make a type
field let's say we were doing this in
JavaScript we would make that string Lea
type two you would represent that as a
string and then straight every student
have a student discount
which is a number between 0 and 100 so
let's say when I was a student I had a
student discount or 50% at some shop
then I started working at Beck and I
would I change into a corporate customer
so now I'm a student discount is 0 I
can't just not have it there I need to
have access to the student accounts it
needs to be 0 so it's kind of misleading
it has to be there but we really like it
not be there so we have a couple of
problems you get empty fields dummy
values it's very easy to miss type to
type field let's say you write student
without a t there's no help and also no
help from the compiler if you have some
function that accepts that type it
wouldn't know that the only three
possible values were those three so we
need something that resembles an enum in
c-sharp
that's where algebraic data types or
union types as we call them in LM coming
this is really one of my favorite
features because it's so great at
modeling the domain whenever I write
ordinary JavaScript narrow or Java is
always always keep reaching for these
kind of constructions so it's similar to
an enum where you have a type that has a
finite set of possible values so the
customer type can only be a student
corporate or private value but there are
not Singleton's they can be you can
create instances of this and the this is
where the real magic happens the
different branches of a union type can
contain different data so let's say you
have students and then you can say that
in order to make a student value of type
customer type you would need to pass in
the int so student is basically a
function or a constructor that takes an
int similarly with the corporate value
you will need to pass it a string in
order to make a value of that type so
the compiler and then type system will
ensure that whenever you have a student
value you know it will have a name so
it's a bit like enum some steroids I
would say so in order to unwrap these in
the other end you would use what we call
pattern matching where which is
basically like a fancy switch case so
you can just write case and then pointer
to some sort of concept of and all the
different possible values for that type
so you can do this also for arrays or
other types but it's especially
well-suited for union types so we would
basically be able to extract the value
that the Union type is carrying so for
students that means an int the discount
and for corporate values that means the
string the name and we can name this
whatever we want in this case because
the system will know what kind of type
it is and also if you could get a branch
the compiler will tell you and just
refuse to compile your code and this is
also used when you do something like in
a network call then the compiler will be
able to tell you if you've got to handle
the case where the call failed right in
JavaScript
forgetting the other the dot fail
callback is just so easy here the
compiler will make sure that didn't
happen
so this is really it's hard and the hard
to overstate how important this this
mechanic is remodeling your domain I
currently work for the Norwegian Railway
Company and it's bad and ticket is just
not a ticket like there are so many
different kinds of tickets and they are
all really different I spent months and
months trying to wrap my head around at
the main model and having union types of
just helped out so much so let's say I
take it is either a single ticket return
ticket a period ticket a tram ticket or
zone ticket there's even more but I'll
just meet them for clarity and ease yeah
and every one of them would carry a
certain set of data right then you can
say that in order to make a single
ticket instance you would have to give
it a single ticket data record and then
you would know that whenever you were
having a case where you had a single
ticket you knew that it would have these
fields and they would be populated none
of them would be null because you don't
have no and you're home free our current
JavaScript or JSON objects your plans
are presenting this ticket serviced a
mile long with lots of snow and then the
fines so the way we can get rid of null
is by having an optional type so it's
called maybe in elm and use it whenever
you have something that could have a
value but it also just be nothing
basically so and maybe it's either just
something or nothing and a is here
representing a type placeholder or type
variable meaning any type so let's say
you're making a game and whenever you
are having the first playthrough you
wouldn't have a high score until your
game session ended so then you would
have a maybe int or maybe high score and
you would again just use pattern
matching to make sure you knew what to
do in in case of it being just a high
score or Nothing and you have several
kinds of these constructs you also have
a task which is something that can feel
like a network call or trying to fetch
the first element in the list because
the list can be empty etc so again the
compiler has your back and that's pretty
much the like the tagline of L
when it comes to putting an application
together you have what's called the LM
architecture and this is actually the
inspiration for redux the hugely popular
JavaScript library created a couple of
years ago by this guy called Dan Abramov
he he fooled around with Elm and thought
it was so cool and they was thinking we
need this in JavaScript this is a great
pattern the only bad part is that you
don't have the compiler making sure
you're handling every case in JavaScript
you have to just make sure you you hope
you do that yourself so this is the way
the Elm architecture works you need to
have some app state and that's typically
typically done by creating a type alias
that has all your data that we call
model and then you have the view
function that knows how to represent
that model as HTML so it's basically a
function from model to HTML and that
HTML may emit some events like if the
user clicks on a button or interact with
an input field you don't need to know
what kind of type does that event have
that's the the deal with video that's
the story of HTML message and a message
is basically like in redux action it's
an object that represent it represents
what happened in your application like
user clicked on product button user
timed out fetch user succeeded etc etc
then you have the update function that
defines how the model should be changed
when something happens basically so it
has a signature it accepts a message
what happened and what was the previous
state of your application and then
finally you should return the new state
of your application
so if this reminds you of redux is
because it is basically and the final
thing subscriptions is how you can tell
the Elm architecture that you would like
to subscribe to certain things like a
WebSocket or it notifies me every 100
milliseconds because I'm updating the
game loop or notify meme and the user it
has clicked any buttons on the keyboard
like globally on the page etc sometimes
you need to be able to interrupt
JavaScript it's not very easy in in Elm
I guess interrupt between F sharp and C
sharp is a lot easier and other
compile to JavaScript languages are a
lot easier to interact with chairs than
Elm and the reason for that is that
general JavaScript fails right all the
time
so you basically don't want to interact
with JavaScript but say sometimes you
need to so we need to have the escape
hatch so that's done with something
called ports which is basically a
message passing like a pub/sub system
where you pass strings to your other
script and you get strings back so the
ecosystem is of course really
microscopic compared to JavaScript but
it's growing and I personally haven't
felt that I didn't have anything that I
needed at the time like a component or
some some sort of functionality but
there are some good parts about the
ecosystem as well because since you it
is a strongly and statically typed
language you can do a lot of cool things
like you can enforce semantic versioning
the first release of a library has to be
1.0.0 and remember you you change your
public API the unpackage module will
enforce that you actually bump your
major version similarly it can enforce
that you have documentation for all your
public facing functions and packages
cannot use ports because ports can fail
so if you use a third-party package you
know that the package will function
basically again there's this huge
function focus on correctness robustness
so I'm going to implement a small app
for you to show the IDE the current
tooling how it works basically I'm going
to create a counter app maybe not the
most exciting application but it's a
little old one that I guess you have
seen before
so I figured it would be good to just
start with some code that doesn't
compile so here you have the error
message from the compiler to the right
in the browser and we have Adam running
some displaying some own code to the
left the main function in elm is what is
outputted to the screen so I'm trying to
output the string but the error message
is saying that the main value has an
unsupported type so main only
understands how to present HTML SVG or
this magical program type which is
basically the Elm architecture so I need
to turn my string into one of these
three so let's use a text function and
that text function transformed my string
to an HTML text node which is of type
HTML so from our counter app we will
need some data which is basically just
the number so let's start by creating
the type alias model which is just an
int so in every other app model it would
typically be a large type alias with
with a record lots of key value fields
and we could create a model and start
with just being 0 and notice when I save
everything just the code is just moved
around and that's this lovely little
tool called Elm format which is made by
a third party a community member what it
does is the same thing as prettier in
JavaScript so prettier was pretty much
inspired by this tool so it formats your
code as per the recognized best
practices and the code shared
conventions in elm so meaning that every
time you save your code looks like every
other element code is it's formatted in
the same way and in the beginning that
might feel really awkward or frustrating
because you may be really like your code
before matters in this way but there's a
huge upside here because every time you
open a new own project that project will
look exactly the same as all the other
projects that are using M format and
that's a pretty huge deal to me as a
consultant consultant working with
different projects different clients
imagine opening an old code code base
that hasn't been
worked it for a while and you just
everything's familiar right so I there
was this guy who Ryan Hicks he he said
that using Elm format it's like having
this robot Butler following you around
like cleaning up your messes everywhere
you go that's pretty much how it works
so let's try to print this number to the
screen so we'll have to to string it
which is a global yellow 8 available
method there we go and we could try to
to make a view function to present this
instead so the view function takes our
model and returns an HTML with something
we currently don't have an event
describing user interaction so we'll
just do this you see it's expecting me
to actually implement the function so I
need to do that so doing HTML in Elm is
like doing HTML in react without using a
JSX
so every HTML element has a create as a
function that creates it for you so do
you have a div function to span function
the image function the p function etc
and they all have the same type
signature they take two lists the first
listing a list of attributes like ID
class on clicked etc and the second list
being all the children inside that
element so let's start with a div where
with our text there we go and let's add
some buttons to increment and decrement
this number so we can't just render the
throughout P can't just render the the
plus letter in itself because we need to
turn it into a text node right that's
the first thing we did when you started
coding so if you're thinking that this
formatting looks a little bit weird it's
because it is weird compared to
JavaScript or many other languages but
it's based on what's the easiest to
maintain and work with and read let's
say I didn't want this line anymore I
could just delete it altogether and
didn't have to move the trailing comma
and the line above so I really had some
some a hard time with this in the
beginning but after you just learn to
accept it it's really nice to work with
an LM format just fixes it for you so
now we have two buttons the next thing
to do would be to specify what should
happen when or what are the things that
can happen in our application and that's
modeled through a union type called
message which is basically just a
convention so in this app you have
either the increment thing that can
happen or you have decrement and they
don't need to wrap any data they're just
you just need to know that hey this
thing happened you don't need to know
that hey this thing happened with this
data right so now we need our update
function which is cell a third part of a
bigger program so the update function
takes a message namely what happened and
it takes the old state and you should
return the new state so here as we can
just simply create the the the simplest
thing that we possibly work for me and I
can just see that it's still compiles so
I know I didn't introduce any major
breaking bugs I could of course these
are logical errors but you know that
although like a building blocks just get
together so here we use the pattern
matching to basically switch on which
which events happen that was it the
increment or decrement so this is a case
case they expression I just I love doing
this because Adam kind of course know
all of all the different possible values
so in a huge app with like let's say a
hundred different messages that would
that's a pretty nice feature it's in the
increment case with return model plus
not zero but one and
branch we would return model minus one
so the only problem now is that we're
still just displaying the view function
one time like hard-coded XML so here we
need to use the Elm architecture which
has these two or three functions first
it has a beginner program which is what
I showed you earlier and it has the
program and it has a program with flags
that allows you to do some input
parameters when you when you boot your
application so we basically set the
review function to be the view function
our model to be the model and our update
function to be the update it works but
we're not done yet because we didn't add
on click event handlers to our HTML so
now the like the event loop of Elm isn't
hasn't been being fired so we have
imported our own click up here from the
HTML events package we just need to add
it down here let's do that
so what we're doing instead of a yeah
let's just keep it that like that so
what we're doing instead of the
JavaScript way of passing the function
and say do this for me we'd rather just
say notify me by triggering this kind of
message because that's more declarative
it's just the review function isn't the
right place to handle that you click
them something so the problem now is
that our HTML is submitting an event it
may even meet one of two events like the
increment a value or the decrement value
but both both of those have the type of
message for the capital M but we've
stated in our type signature that it
will emit whatever because whenever it
starts with a lowercase letter it's just
a PI placeholder so it could be anything
I could call it like yeah whatever
basically so we'll have to change that
to message so that our app is totally
type safe there we go so this pretty
small example just illustrates the use
of the type alias representing the model
how many union types were representing
all the things that may happen in our
application the F date function that
actually changes the model when ever
something happens and then you have the
view function to two-percent your data
and of course any of any real L map
would be much more big than this one so
you basically compose it with functions
such as doing functional programming and
maybe your update function is divided
into you just move the like different
branches if you're up the attention out
in two different files basically so this
is there's this big 4,000 line real
world example of Elm made by Richard
Feldman one of them like the biggest
most famous people in town that's freely
available on github so I would encourage
you to check that out if you want to see
a bigger example of Elm so let's go back
to the slides yeah
I'll repeat the question
so the question was does it bother me
that there's a lot of blank lines
introduced by um format when it could
have been much more condensed right so
no in my opinion itself problem I'd
rather have more sparse and more
readable code than like really dense
code I get that I guess that's just a
matter of personal opinion so that's
that's the way I'm works it's very
opinionated so either you like it or
don't but in my experience if you
embrace it it's really it gives you a
lot of value basically so the only way
to find out try it I guess so of course
the obvious advantages of using helm is
the robustness and type safety and it's
so much easier to do a large scale with
factories I mean you could basically
refactor a huge app and then just be
pointed around your codebase by the
compiler I guess we're all used to this
by working with compiled languages on
the back end but on the front end it
really hasn't been like that for a long
time and to me working with different
projects different clients comes to just
consolidate the architecture aspect and
frame like the reduction of the amount
of frameworks it'll use and formatting
this is a huge win so you know that
every codebase will have the pretty much
the same layout and both in terms of
formatting but also in terms of
structure another thing I didn't point
out is that you have the main function
which is the the only thing that can
render things the screen but let's say
let's take a your average JavaScript
application your every single line of
that application could potentially touch
the Dom right
you would never know you could in the
bottom of like in the smallest most less
important file you could be doing some
really bad stuff with your application
it's really hard to see and the learning
curve compared to other functional
languages is in my experience really low
we did a workshop here me and my
colleague in guard this Monday and I
really feel it's a lot easier to learn
on other functional languages so it's I
said
a gateway into the function of the world
and since this is helped by this small
but expressive language course so it's a
they're doing some pretty tough
decisions the guy who writes Elm
to exclude very powerful abstractions
that you have in scale and other
languages just to ensure it's relatively
easy to learn that being said it's I
think it's kind of funny that one of the
biggest disadvantages is that the
learning curve of FP is for some people
still a bit tough I mean you can't just
sit down and in one week not just just
grasp it I think you can grasp Elm much
faster than you can grasp with
JavaScript with react with Redux with
typescript with this and with that but
it's not like a framework you'll learn
in a night and another thing I'm a bit
anxious to see the web development of is
the dictator driven development of Elm
this basically just one guy who made elm
and he still has to be a firm grip on
the Rings I mean there are other people
helping out and doing commits in the
compiler and such but it's still very
much him name's Evan and he's calling
all the shots
so still far all the shots have been
pretty good in my opinion but I mean
it's a bit of it's a bit of a fair ways
compared to the open JavaScript world
and of course you have the small but
growing ecosystem for some people this
is a showstopper and for some other
people the the the small that expressive
core of elm is not expressive enough
they want type classes or higher candid
types of I don't know all their names
but like this Haskell heavy functional
concepts that allow you to be a lot more
expressive but in turn makes the
compiler error so much worse and the
language so much harder to learn so Elam
has been around for quite some time it's
been five years it's been attracting a
lot of attention and generating
conference talks I think I not
overstating it when pretty much every
conference these days have a talk or Elm
workshop but is it really ready for
production does anyone actually use Elm
for their mission-critical user-facing
apps and if so what are their stories
so this is something I wanted to ask
myself and I went out to try to answer
this question
and the reason I'm able to answer that
to some degree is that we are we wanted
to really start building an elm
community last year so it's through the
Elm community I've been meeting a lot of
different people so it's not like a
scientific survey with the qualitative
data so and it might contain biased
answers but this is basically me talking
to a large part of the Elm community in
also in Norway so they also L meet-up is
something we started last year it has
about 300 members now we do monthly
meetups where people do show and tells
that are quite short and sweet like 15
20 minutes and then the rest of the
session is basically coding meeting new
people and asking people more experience
with Elm done yourself for difficult
difficult questions you have as a trap
also we started a conference this spring
that was held this weekend actually
because there was this conference called
Elm Europe and we invited like the
biggest speaker from Elm Europe to come
take a detour from Paris to also to talk
about Elmen he said yeah sure he'll do
it it's actually the same guy who made
the real world example a real world 4000
Lion example so it's a real experience
to Elm developer and we decided to hey
what the heck let's just do a conference
and we were actually able to gather 105
people and also for discussing Elm and
that's when I really saw like the like
the breadth of the Elm communities it
really isn't like 10 people anymore it
really starts to be quite a community so
how most people are using Elm they're
they are following the guidelines from
the L blog which is basically it's not
rocket science I guess you just start
small start with a small part of your
app perhaps the most difficult part of
your app that has the most complex logic
that it's really well modeled in a
language like this and introduce that
see how it works in your context you
have a team you like sit and then take
it from there it doesn't work it doesn't
work and so I have this friend who helps
organize Java so and the other big
conference in Oslo and they had to redo
their school
like their info screens and they have
this special made software for that and
that software actually runs outside of
this room right now so NBC also adapted
this app and that's written in L and the
reason he wanted to do it in Elm was of
course the part of it is that they just
wanted to check it out I mean most
developers like testing out new
technology but also that 3,000 of his
friends and colleagues will be watching
that app while it was running and it was
written in all JavaScript framework and
he had really no clue how it worked so
writing his Elm fell to Mike seemed to
make sense
robustness wise so it also has this
back-end where you can push slides
directly to the info app and that can be
either a tweet or some text or a video
or whatever basically so if something
happens on like a the bar opens 16
minutes later than it should have been
doing they just push a new slide to -
this app called switcheroo and there's
also a lot of people at Java zone who
wanted to try out and also some more
traditional back-end developers who
weren't familiar with like the modern
JavaScript stack so they heard hey
there's a compiler and there's some
types saying let's let's try it out and
suddenly there were some more people
writing him that were hadn't been
writing single page apps basically ever
so that's another pretty cool thing
about Elm is that enables more people to
do pretty advanced front-end stuff so
they decided to do their like their call
for papers or call for speakers app also
an elm and that's being adopted by more
and more conferences how I don't think
any C's is using it yet but Java 7 is
using it and the trondheim developer
conference is using it and I guess it's
open source so if you run a conference
and you need a CFP software just hit him
up from Twitter so maybe the biggest Elm
adopter in Norway is this company in
Bergen called 7 desiccating which is
basically a insurance company so they
did this really thorough research on the
state of the art in JavaScript so they
consider JavaScript with typescript pure
script Elm clojurescript
and they just decided that Elm would be
the best fit for their their stuff or
presumably the best fit
they started small just kept growing and
growing and before they knew it they had
re-implemented their entire app
basically so they have said that we will
be writing all our new stuff in elm and
they have about ten developers writing
out a full time or at least part time
they are really dedicated and are also
hiring people that want you to work with
them and that's another dimension so
when you say that hey we use them come
to us if you want to write out that's
also something that should not be taken
lightly because I mean how all these
developers really feel really strongly
about their languages be it f sharp or
closure or haskell or l and there's a
chance your company might actually be
able to hire some really talented people
by being able to supply a job doing a
language that not that's not very
mainstream internally at BEC we've been
trying some to use elm at some like
internal applications so this is our
client employee application and we
decided to do this one because it has a
lot of thing that could pose a challenge
like you have this drop-down and you
should be able to navigate a drop-down
with your arrows and if you click
outside of it it has to be closed so
there we have like there you're not
clicking inside of a component -
clicking outside of something and then
this something should close so that's
also a bit tricky to do but it worked
and also you have these tags and labels
that you can add inside of the search
field and of course we have like the the
the availability stuff that it should be
navigatable by keyboard and by
screenreader so that's why we decided to
tackle this based and we are pretty
close to fully reimplemented it and so
far we've been able to overcome all of
these kind of tricky challenges without
any big problems which are pretty boring
summary I guess but so it's pretty good
to see that we didn't encounter any of
these big roadblocks so there's another
consultancy and also called iterate so
they are doing a lot of like internal
startups making products one of those is
a site called bullet which is like a
platform for people who like to knit
clothes and people who like to wear big
clothes and they made this thing in Elm
just to like as a small project just to
test FL manned test B the idea of course
there's another comparable Blanc making
a like a consultant mark marketplace for
consultants and they pick album for a
very specific reason because they knew
that this thing they knew that they
didn't know what they wanted to build
they just want knew that they wanted to
build something in this space so
choosing helm they knew that they can do
pretty safe prefactors pretty fast while
it's already in production without
having to do a lot of QA and another
interesting thing is that their back-end
is in scale but still they didn't choose
pure script which is a pretty similar to
two-tier SQL and the reason they chose
Elm is because they also knew that they
were having some they were they were
going to onboard some pretty new
developers that from the University and
they wanted to check out if Elm would
work in that context where you get like
a week to fully learn Elm and then be
productive and what they found out is
that actually that this new employee was
productive within a couple days like two
or three days then of course there were
still so long and intensive days
learning Elm but just having the
confidence of the compiler and the type
system is a pretty huge deal so that's
some of the things I want to highlight
from the Norwegian Island community I
know there's a lot of more companies
experimenting building stuff but like
the biggest fish in the water is is this
American company no red ink so that's
where pretty much all the
internationally known Elm people work
and they also decided to hire the guy
who wrote Elm so it's a bit the same
story as to react on Facebook so so Alan
hawse is a my big company backing them I
know they have still thought they were
like a ten people startup in California
but I this weekend I learned to have
offices in like Sweden Denmark Germany
France everywhere so I guess they're
getting quite big they have about 150
thousand lines of elm production that's
pretty huge and they have open sourced a
lot of nice libraries and they're pretty
much like a thought leader in the global
Elm community and they're also flying
out their people to conferences like
Oslo Elm Day for free to to help share
their stories and it's a really feel
that the the Elm community both nor
but also globally it's really welcoming
and easy to to get be a part of so
summary of those project project
experiences is that 100% of them would
use it again for their purpose of course
there's some of them who have been
holding back doing like even bigger
stuff so so the things I've been
building a really pretty safe but it's
nice to see that all of them would use
began they didn't encounter any big
roadblocks that would stop them and the
overall experiences are of course good
but mostly limited to those mold
projects and they all pretty much report
that the of course we like the safety
stuff and robust robustness stuff is
pretty important but also the onboarding
and the developer experience and the
team mobility were like traditional
back-end people suddenly enjoy riding
from pinnacle pretty complex fronting
code and the bad parts is of course the
learning curve if you've done if you
haven't done any functional programming
and you really don't want to learn
functional programming
I guess it's there still is a learning
curve that was the biggest pain point in
the state of elm survey that was
published a couple of weeks ago and of
course if you have this huge react
component library you can't basically
reuse some of that in a very easy manner
because you can't call JavaScript code
directly from helm so that can be a
turn-off for some and of course if you
are this really advanced functional
programming user and you're used to
scale and pure script etc that may be a
better choice for you if you know that
your team will only consist of like
super awesome
Pascal people because you have no type
classes in those kinds of heavy
abstractions you know so we release this
TechRadar put back a couple of weeks ago
and in this radar we we put technologies
in the like adopt assess or with whole
categories and this year we have Elm in
the use or adopt so we think that use
Elm if the team knows functional
programming for before or it's open to
learning and app robustness or safe
refactoring is important to you
and of course the more complex the APIs
or your larger guess the better the use
case for Elm
I might avoid Elm if
speed Trump's quality like if you're a
startup and you just wanted to get
features out into production as fast as
possible and just you wouldn't care like
implementing all the types and making
your system really like error-free I
guess Elm is a bad choice I would lose
them on our conference website we have
this animation running and I wanted to
just like try to tweet it animation see
where I could go with it like pre
creative programming doing that stuff
with alum it's a bit more work because
it has to compile all the time and
you're a bit more constrained by the by
the language so if you're just making a
prototype or just some creative
programming JavaScript would be my tool
10 out of 10 times or something else
that's really really small and of course
if the learning curve would be too big
if the team doesn't know SP or doesn't
want to learn it's also a bad choice so
my to attempt to summarize my favorite
tool in JavaScript world is react Redux
and perhaps I tripped and I feel that's
like you know in Norway there's a lot of
mountains and we try you have to drill a
lot of tunnels to get our trains and
trams and cars through so the
traditional way to to make tones is to
just use TNT and just blow the load
stuff up right but in Europe they're
using a lot more of these things called
tunnel drilling machines that take
months and months and months to
transport and set up but once they're
set up there much quicker and much safer
so I I feel that reactor ducts is like
this big tunnel machine that you have to
set up you have to learn all these
frameworks you have to like get a build
tool to work and you have to there's so
much things you have to do and learn
able to do it and that's why you have
these dedicated front-end developers
well as I feel at Elm is more like the
the works out of the box to set it up
use the LM architecture use L format and
you're good to go you have a great tool
that will enable you to write big
complex applications so it's delightful
to use I really think so apps are easy
to maintain
it enables our team to be all fully
full-stack the functional learning curve
may be tough for some but I think the
following year will be really exciting
to see if this catches on in our way and
in the community as a whole so to go
back to my initial
complaints with the current state of
JavaScript I really feel Elms checks off
all of these I hope I piqued your
interest if I did
please try l get in touch with the new
region l community join the monthly
meetups that's meetup.com slash also L
Meetup there's this dedicated elm slack
that has this official goal of answering
every question and helping every
individual who wants to help help so if
you ask a question they're either on the
Norway channel or on the general Channel
and don't get response just ping one of
like the high profile end people and
they will direct you to someone that
will help you that's a part of the
policy and also please follow L also elm
day on Twitter if you would be
interested in coming to our next edition
of the conference and lastly but most
importantly just make something just go
through the Elm website and try the
in-browser Elm compiler ray you can just
tick around with the code make a small
app make a small part of your your app
at work in Elm see if it works for your
context and that's pretty much it thank
you